et ça va ensuite voler de succès en
succès et ça donne aujourd'hui des
journées de 48 heures et je vous propose
de suivre une journée de michel drucker
et c'est un reportage de jean pierre
spiero et d'alain valentini oui je
commente un peu alors là il est 6h30
comment vous avez également appris à
commenter super mais alors là j'arrive à
europe 1 il est 6h30
je vais à la rédaction dire bonjour aux
confrères skis jean le bail
ces gens arrivent deux heures à peu près
avant l'émission
yvan est là depuis 4 heures du matin et
ensuite à 7h25 je rentre dans le studio
de ji chn eir 6 piles
bonjour michel lundi 21 novembre 66e
numéro de studio 1 voulait le programme
pour sa coque et charden valide a eu mon
temps file et diane tell françois rené
duchâble pierre-michel indications des
collaborateurs de l'émission prend le
petit déjeuner vers 7h15 maryse qui a
besoin de la voir ses amis etc comme
l'aisne enfin suis collé entre
guillemets parce que je crois qu'on est
un peu plus de collègues ça c'est mon
père
messieurs
michel drucker présent
il
pourquoi les hommes là sont comme chez
vous mais par le froid du show dance est
ce que vous voulez dire madame soleil
michel et qu'elles signent vierge
ascendant vierge
alors est ce que vous pouvez me dire un
tas de choses là dessus d'ailleurs il
est très représentatif de son signe il
est mince élégant toujours soigné
anxieux
perfectionniste très difficile pour son
travail parce qu'il ne laisse rien au
hasard tout est calculé décidé au quart
de tour c'est la perfection à personne
mais avec le charme lâche antillaise
mercure l'art de vous envelopper
gentiment en vous passant la main seul
dans le dos il veut faire tout ce que
vous voulez et lorsqu'il veut surtout
bonjour c'était moi avec ses 10
deschamps tort canadienne donne beaucoup
parce qu' ils nous aident beaucoup
lorsqu'on arrive en france on a une
antenne à combien de retard ce matin
qu'une 0,3 alors que le 6 mai alors que
le bail alors qu alors que pierre était
pas celle de bâle a subi très
concrètement c'est indéfendable
alors là c'est là je quitte la rue
françois 1er je vais avenue gabriel pour
retrouver l'équipe de change elysées
c'est à dire françoise coquet vous allez
découvrir françoise hamel philippe
allain ce jour là c'était le réalisateur
dire sanders
c'est le mardi après midi et là je
répète une chanson c'est pourquoi on
garde encore le secret
il est quelle heure après la la il est 3
heures 15 heures
on voit qu'après sioniste là
effectivement oui merci dieu sait ce
qu'il en est
c'est le plateau et nous arrive de nous
très mais quand le plateau est vidée
pour calmer les angoisses et puis pour
réfléchir à l'émission pour notre
solution plus en plus alors ça c'est la
salle ça c'est le bureau où travaillent
à essayer dé dire que 109 et françoise
coquet que voici
j'ai de la chance d'être entouré par de
jolies femmes les remarquer hier
française amel marie-christine et puis
toute l'équipe une équipe que vous
connaissez inchangé alors c'est le mardi
ou très lentement et souvent dans la
folie on fait ce qu'on appelle le
conducteur de l'émission pour mettre au
point les missions du samedi que nous
répétons à partir du jeudi vendredi
samedi aura pas de trois jours et et ça
ce sont nos gardiens si j'ose dire
puisque nous habitons à nous travaillons
derrière l'elysée
et derrière l'ambassade des états unis
ce qui fait d avant un service musclé
pour les raisons que vous imaginez vous
à 8 heures à 8 heures à cash kapisa dans
la mesure du possible si on est libre
rien
hélas et je rentre chez moi tous les
soirs vers 7h30 19h45 car je dîne chez
moi je ne sors jamais le soir ça fait
les gens de mieux remplir et je
travaille le soir encore car j'ai la
chance d'avoir d'avoir mes propres
archives que j'ai mis au point que j'ai
commencé il ya 12 ans qui sont qui sont
mises à jour tous les jours par mon
épouse pendant des années maintenant il
ya un assistant qui a pris le relais
ces trois quatre heures de travail par
jour pour savoir tout ce qui se dit sur
tous les gens de notre métier en france
à l'étranger en province honecker de
presse essentiellement absolument tout
tout ce qui paraît quotidiennement c'est
à dire si un article vous concernant
sherman et que votre émission
aujourd'hui sera archivé ce soir et
j'espère que j'ai le regret est une
chose drôle et amusante à écouter ça
fait 12 ans que je ris bien avec lui
parce que les téléspectateurs et les
auditeurs le connaissent sous un jour
clie dans la vie dans la réalité le même
mais multiplié par 5 ou 6 c'est à dire
que lorsqu à la radio il fait rire ses
auditeurs je peux vous dire qu'à la
maison on rit quatre ou cinq fois plus
parce qu'il a un caractère très enjoué
qu'il est il a beaucoup d'humour il sait
imiter
tous les gens qu'il a rencontrés dans sa
journée il s'est très très bien attraper
des personnages et et les recréer
totalement et quand je dis on je veux
dire ma fille et moi puisque nous vivons
tous les trois et c'est vrai que la vie
est très drôle avec lui est ce que le
vieux reposante
pas vraiment non la vie n'est pas très
reposante
elle n'est pas très reposante parce que
il est très très occupé comme vous le
savez je le vois finalement deux heures
par jour puisqu'il arrive vers 20h30 le
temps de dîner je lui fais à manger le
temps de débarrasser la table c'est fini
les déjà couché il dort alors ça c'est
c'est le petit problème et je vous dis
pendant c'est pendant ces deux heures
c'est un véritable tourbillon parce que
même lorsqu'il arrive après une journée
de labeur
il rentre à la maison il a encore du
punch et il a encore beaucoup de
vivacité et c'est pas très reposant elle
avait faim n'est pas parce que bien des
caméras sinon c'est beaucoup plus les
excès de gourmandise est mis au lit pour
faire le plein de ma serviette par danie
thiart beaucoup rencontrer
l'organisation des champs elysées savent
toujours alors la delahaye très souvent
3 3 fois par semaine je suis pas trop
fatigué je travaille dans ce but un
petit peu plus tard parce que j'ai
commencé il ya déjà un an et demi un
ouvrage tout ça je voudrais pas besoin